[Musik]
ich bin nicht stolz drauf in einem land
zu leben in dem alle brach sturm
bis vor einem jahr war ludwig herold
koch in berlin songs wie diesen schreibt
er nebenbei den job als koch verlor
gleich im märz 2020 im ersten lockdown
als hotels und gaststätten das erste mal
schließen mussten
dem 27-jährigen war schnell klar es muss
sich nur ein neuer job
es muss am besten gleich ein ganz neuer
beruf her ich habe mich mit meinem vater
natürlich drüber unterhalten und das ich
überlege was ich jetzt mache ich etwas
aus giesen sicher ist vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr abwirft als den
mindestlohn ich gebe keine zu hause bei
seinem vater
er ist dozent für notfallmedizin und
bildet in hamburg rettungspersonal aus
im zweiten lockdown beschließen sie den
neuanfang für sohn ludwig er soll
rettungssanitäter werden krisensicher
und systemrelevant für seine ausbildung
zum rettungssanitäter bittet ludwig
herold die arbeitsagentur im november um
finanzielle unterstützung zwei tage
bevor sein kurs in hamburg beginnt bei
seiner sachbearbeiterin im arbeitsamt
pankow kommt diese eigeninitiative gar
nicht gut an
reise und kurs habe er ohne ihre
zustimmung an getreten
das amt schreibt uns dazu zitat unter
diesen voraussetzungen stand er den
vermittlungsbemühungen der agentur für
arbeit ab november 2020 nicht mehr zur
verfügung was nach dem sozialgesetzbuch
drei zur aufhebung der finanziellen
leistungen führte
ich glaube zu helfen streicht ihm das
arbeitsamt das arbeitslosengeld etwas
über 700 euro das ist eine bestrafung
obwohl man ja eigentlich was richtig
machen will ich wollte was machen meint
ernst und geld auf 0 das war das was wir
ein absolut nicht kapiert haben mitten
in der krise steht er ohne
arbeitslosengeld da noch aus hamburg
ruft er beim arbeitsamt an
dort gibt es kein erbarmen ich fahr
sofort nach berlin und dann brauche ich
jetzt auch nicht mehr machen muss
rückwirkend gestrichen
sie sind nicht mehr arbeitslos ja wir
führen sie nicht mehr aber ist was das
heißt er war also rückwirkend nicht nur
nicht mehr arbeitslos sondern eben auch
dass er nicht mehr kann versichert und
das fange schon schon ziemlich hart
gemeinsam mit seinem rechtsanwalt
verklagt er das arbeitsamt aufzahlung
das problem
arbeitslose dürfen ihren wohnort nur mit
genehmigung der arbeitsagentur verlassen
er war zu schnell das ist vom gesetz
nicht vorgesehen
das gesetz erwartet von einem
arbeitslosen zu hause sitzen und auf
post vom amt warten
das gesetz ist immer noch publik also da
kommt die idee her dieses ständige gehen
ja das heißt man wartet sozusagen neben
dem briefkasten dass ein
vermittlungsangebot kommt von der
bundesagentur für arbeit so dass mal
sogleich zu behörden gehen kann um sich
dort zu heben
das ist natürlich im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert so eine sache
ich weiß nicht wie häufig bei musik sein
muss sich permanent in der wohnung
sitzen mit einer fahrkarte land die die
ich nur stempel muss ich weiß nicht wie
sie sich das vorstellen welchen sinn
macht es außerdem sich als koch am
wohnort bereit zu halten denn
gaststätten gerade geschlossen sind mein
geld auf null zu setzen war für die
einfach nur einen arbeits- griff und die
sahen ich den menschen dahinter der
bisher von paar millionen ja ich bin die
nummer als koch sieht er keine zukunft
mehr
obwohl er das dem amt mitgeteilt habe
schicken die weiterhin
vermittlungsvorschläge allesamt als co
insgesamt achtmal das hält das amt für
erfolgsversprechend
daran würde ich mir sehr sehr große
fragezeichen dran machen
der gewerkschafter zwar fehlt nicht nur
daran dass das gerade gut bezahlte jobs
sind er rechnet auch nach der pandemie
mit 30 prozent weniger arbeitsplätzen in
der gastronomie
aktuell ist jedenfalls aus unserer sicht
eher pessimistisch zu betrachten
manchmal hat man den eindruck dass der
mitarbeiter in behörden sitzen die sich
möglicherweise einen vorschriften fest
tackern die einfach mit der
lebensrealität aktuell der menschen
nichts zu tun hat ich habe erwartet dass
man mir helfen kann und so wie jetzt
alles aussieht
er hätte ich einfach mal die klappe
gehalten
das lesen mediale haben die frist die
verfällt für den start was dunumer
stellen für einen stempel aus ab dann
kostest du geld also hoch weil das du
fällst wie soll ich bin stolz auf mich
aktuell hat deutschland rund 500.000
mehr arbeitslose menschen als vor der
pandemie in berlin wurden tausende köche
arbeitslos trotzdem kennt die
arbeitsagentur für ludwig herold nur
eine perspektive
denn rettungssanitäter so schreibt uns
die agentur für arbeit sei erstens zitat
kein anerkannter ausbildungsberuf und 2
betrachtet man den arbeitsmarkt für
küche ist eine integration als berufs
erfahrener koch deutlich
erfolgsversprechender an seinem alten
arbeitsplatz hangeln sie sich von
lockdown zu lockdown und fragen wo
sollen gerade all diese jobs im
gastgewerbe seien
ich würde gerne wissen wo die
arbeitsagentur dann wirklich ihre zahlen
erholt weil wo findet man dann in der
gastronomie gerade wirklich einen festen
beruf ich meine allein hier bei uns in
der gemeinde haben zwei restaurants
komplett zu gemacht die haben es nicht
geschafft vorbei im kastanienhof hat
ludwig herold acht jahre lang als koch
gearbeitet bis corona kam und dass hier
keine arbeit mehr für ihn gab
weil nicht einfach meine ist es auch
mein bester freund hat das immer dabei
gewesen und der gedanke hoch aber wir
mussten noch einfach gucken wo wir
bleiben und das sollten wir mal das
heißt jede müsste klar sein auch den
sachbearbeitern vom amt das die gastro
gerade einfach mal gucken gehen und
aufstehen das geschäft das wären weiß
nicht wie lange das noch geht beim
hotel- und gaststättenverband gibt schon
jetzt jeder vierte unternehmer an er
stehe vor der aufgabe seines betriebes
für berlin hieße dass viele weitere 1000
arbeitslose allein in der gastronomie
wenn die befürchtung stimmen dass 30%
und ihr unternehmen aufgeben
dann kann man schon von ungefähr 30.000
arbeitslosen ausgeben
das ist natürlich ein wunder um eine
katastrophe die arbeitsagentur kennt die
aktuellen zahlen bundesweit suchen
danach bereits rund 22.000 köche neue
jobs rettungssanitäter bundesweit
dagegen nur 380 wie konnte da die 1
zeitung gegen jemand ausfallen der sich
mitten in der pandemie zum
rettungssanitäter ausbilden lässt
das ist als wenn sie da einfach und
sagen den tipp immer auf dieselbe taste
macht jetzt immer nur dass das ist das
richtige das ist das gesetz danach musst
du gehen kannst da nicht irgendwas
anderes entscheiden weil das ist ja ist
immer das gleiche
egal was für eine situation draußen ist
das hatte ich nicht zu interessieren wie
meinten ja dann auch das
rettungssanitäter es keine anerkannte
ausbildung und klar und hier und da und
das sucht doch keiner also medizin wird
mich gebraucht also da hoffe ich dass
das die leute dann nicht wirklich mal
ein rtw im brauchen oder darauf
angewiesen sind also ich kann
versprechen dass ich da natürlich mein
bestes tun werde und auf meinen job dann
auch besser mache als die iren die
arbeitsagentur bleibt dabei es würden
immer noch deutlich mehr köche als
rettungssanitäter gesucht obwohl
rettungsdienste krankenhäuser und
krankentransporter um rettungssanitäter
ringen in berlin wird ein klinikverbund
sogar mit der zahlung von vermittlungs
bringen das heißt sie suchen wie
verrückt es werden egal ob pandemie
nicht wahnsinnig seit jahren seit
jahrzehnten rettungssanitäter gesucht
nicht nur rettungssanitäter sondern eben
auch notfallsanitäter und
krankenschwestern und krankenpfleger und
ärzte und altenpfleger dass es bekannt
und erst recht in der pandemie ein jahr
nach corona müssen demnächst mehrere
hunderttausend arbeitslose ohne neuen
job hartz 4 beantragen
für ludwig herold aber beginnt bald das
praktikum als rettungssanitäter
seine der werse lusti gezielt in den
dosen ein topf ist